[Music]
his legacy is in the modest things
around us
sir terence conrad is credited with
bringing stylish and useful home decor
to the mass market he did this from the
early 1940s
making his furniture first by hand
before factory producing and innovating
flat-packed goods in the 1980s he
founded the design museum in a converted
banana warehouse on the london south
bank
a space for the design community to be
represented
now here in kensington terrence
had a unquenching optimism he always
believed that you could find something
to do things
better he really believed that
design could make everyday life just a
bit nicer just a bit pleasanter
and he really wanted to share that with
everyone and last london sunshine joined
in the welcome to the royal visitors as
they arrived at the southbank site
of the festival of britain sir terence
would say his greatest moments were what
he designed at the festival of britain
in 1951.
to me the festival of britain was a
pivotal
changing point when we understood
how important design is
to our nation both from a
cultural point of view and also from an
economic point of view
born in 1931 in kingston upon thames
ceterans studied textile design
he opened more than 50 restaurants
across the country and in 1964 launched
the home furniture brand habitat
the company went on to incorporate other
household brands including mother care
and british home stores
his ideas weren't just modest but they
survived and inspired decades of
changing trends
he was largely responsible after habitat
for creating the modern chains
in the beginning of that you know
he created quite an empire post the
habitat period
it was quite unique and that was when it
was like she was 60 years old it was
not a young man to go again you know
after creating that one empire he
created another he may not have been a
household name for many
but sir terence leaves behind an
enormous legacy of household design
saudia chowdhury sky news